et
où
mes chers compatriotes mes véritables
anges de l'élection présidentielle c'est
le bien-être des français
votre bien-être et la condition de ce
bien-être
c'est la réussite et la grandeur de la
france tout le monde vous parle de
justice sociale si bien mais pour
réaliser la justice sociale il faut que
la france créent les richesses
nécessaires et donc gagnent la bataille
économique que j'ai engagé il y a deux
ans est aussi que chaque français et sa
juste part des fruits de la réussite
l'enjeu de l'élection présidentielle
n'est pas de savoir qui va gagner du
peuple de gauche ou du peuple de droite
il s'agit de choisir entre la france qui
perd et la france qui gagne
pour tous les français de 1981 à 1986
sous l' empire des socialistes notre
pays a pris cinq ans de retard sur ses
voisins et sur ses concurrents ne vous y
trompez pas socialisme aujourd'hui même
s'il ne veut plus dire son nom
même si son candidat déclare ne pas
avoir de programme n'en est pas pour
autant moins dangereux depuis deux ans
j'ai entrepris le redressement de la
france et les premiers résultats sont là
je croise à la sagesse de mes
compatriotes
ils savent juger sur les actes et ne se
contente pas de bonnes paroles pour que
la france gagne
voici ce qu'il faut faire et si vous me
fait confiance je le ferai
il faut achever de remettre l'état à sa
vraie place
réduire les déficits et les endettements
il faut donner plus de liberté et
d'initiatives aux citoyens et donner aux
entreprises la possibilité de se
développer pour investir
et créer des emplois il faut maintenir
la protection sociale est donné à tous
jeunes et moins jeunes par l'éducation
et par la formation la première dignité
de l'homme avoir un travail il faut
renforcer la politique familiale et
donner enfin aux femmes la liberté
d'élever leurs enfants et d'avoir une
activité professionnelle
il faut garantir la sécurité pour tous
et ne pas transiger sur la défense de la
france et sa place dans le monde
il faut définir ensemble une politique
de l'immigration qui respecte à la fois
notre identité nationale
et bien entendu les droits de l'homme
quand on croit comme je crois au génie
de la france on ne peut pas accepter et
je n'accepte pas qu'un français hommes
ou femmes restent sur le bord de la
route parce qu'à 55 ans il a perdu son
emploi parce qu'ils les seules ou âgées
ou handicapées il ne suffit pas que la
collectivité se donnent bonne conscience
en distribuant seulement des allocations
il faut aller au devant de ceux qui ont
besoin de nous et les aider à trouver ou
à retrouver leur place toute leur place
dans notre société
mais nous ne pourrons gagner ensemble
que si la france retrouve son rang en
europe car c'est là que se joue notre
destin elle était la première il ya 20
ans par son dynamisme
elle peut le redevenir et il le faut
cela ne dépend que de vous et du choix
que vous ferez le 24 avril et le 8 mai
et de toutes mes forces et de tout mon
coeur je veux faire de la france pour
chacun d'entre nous un pays
or plus libre plus juste mieux
rassembler et plus fraternelle